Shawn Mendes and Camila Cabello packing
on the PDA
[Music]
the former Flames sparking more romance
rumors cuddling up ahead of a comedy
show in Los Angeles the two looking
extra flirty holding each other close
and we can't help but notice that big
smile on Camilla's face
true
[Music]
but the pair is not running this outing
marks yet another public sighting
together since they locked lips at
Coachella it just feels like oh my God
like we're kissing now last month Sean
and Camila walked hand in hand during a
night stroll in Santa Monica and I
witnessed told E.T at the time they
looked very comfortable happy and in
love oh my God this is a real thing just
days after that sighting Camila dropped
this
don't miss whatever if you do honey I'm
here think about a 20-second snippet of
a new track titled June Gloom those
lyrics about Coachella a coincidence we
think not
so much better is this gonna end ever
we don't really put any rules or
boundaries those feelings are gonna come
and I think you just gather more and
more tools to cope with them in like
healthy ways Camila and Sean called it
quits in late 2021 but now seems they're
giving their romance another shot
[Music]
last month A source told ET they aren't
officially back together but they're
enjoying each other's company and seeing
where things go I think the truth about
being celebrities and being in a
relationship is that it's super tricky
because
there's a lot of people who want to know
our source adds that Sean and Camila are
attracted to each other and care about
each other a lot simply put they're
having fun
[Music]